Damen und Herren herzlich willkommen
hier im Konrad-Adenauer-Haus vielen Dank
für jeden Interesse in diesen Zeiten die
Parteivorsitzenden von CDU und CSU Armin
Laschet und Markus Söder haben sowohl
der FDP als auch Bündnis 90 den Grünen
ein Angebot zum Gespräch unterbreitet
dieses Angebot ist angenommen worden und
wir glauben dass es Sinn macht darüber
zu sprechen ob es eine Möglichkeit gibt
ein zukunftsbündnis zu schmieden was
insbesondere die ganze gesellschaftliche
Breite und die Themen die in unserer
Gesellschaft diskutiert werden auch
abbildet und Brücken baut das könnte
eine Koalition für Nachhaltigkeit sein
Nachhaltigkeit in jeder Dimension bei
der Frage des Klimaschutzes aber auch
bei der Frage von Nachhaltigkeit im
Bereich der Finanzierung des
Staatswesens bei der Frage von einem
eines modernen Staates aber auch in der
Frage der Digitalisierung unseres Landes
das im Hinblick gerade auf die jungen
Menschen in unserem Land ist ein großer
Anspruch und es macht Sinn dafür zu
arbeiten
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren in
diesem Sinne wollen wir miteinander
sprechen wir machen ein Angebot unser
Angebot beruht auf unserer inhaltlichen
Ausrichtung die wir festgeschrieben
haben auch in den Beschlüssen die wir
zuletzt getroffen haben insbesondere auf
Grundlage des Wahlprogramms von CDU und
CSU wir haben gerade im Präsidium
darüber beraten es gibt eine große
Mehrheit dafür diese Gespräche zu führen
wir haben auch unsere Delegation
zusammengestellt und werden am
Sonntagabend um 18 Uhr 30 zusammenkommen
mit den Freien Demokraten und am
Dienstagvormittag mit Bündnis 90 den
Grünen wir gehen sehr ernsthaft in diese
Gespräche und wir gehen natürlich auch
mit einer Offenheit bezüglich der
anderen Positionen in diese Gespräche
weil wir Brücken bauen wollen weil es
wichtig ist dass dieses Land gut geführt
wird und
nachhaltig in die Zukunft geht alles
andere werden die Gespräche zeigen
dann die erste Frage bitte Jörg blank
dpa
teamiac sie haben eben gesagt es gab
eine große Mehrheit im Präsidium war
nicht alle dafür gab es auch Stimmen die
gesagt haben man sollte jetzt gleich in
die Opposition gehen und die zweite
Frage nach dem Frau Göring Eckert heute
gesagt hat die Union ja sei im Moment ja
weder Regierungs noch sondierungsfähig
wie wollen Sie denn die Grünen und die
FDP überzeugen dass das anders ist das
werden wir dann in den Gesprächen tun
wir haben wir sind davon überzeugt dass
wir ein gutes Angebot haben und über
dieses Angebot muss man sprechen wir
haben keinen Anspruch kein
Rechtsanspruch aber wir haben ein
Angebot und die anderen haben auch ein
Angebot und sie haben gute Ergebnisse
bei diesen Wahlen erzielt FDP und Grüne
wir haben dazu alle Parteien
beglückwünscht die Zuwächse bei dieser
Bundestagswahl erzielt haben und jetzt
geht es darum zu schauen welche
Koalition möglich ist ich wir sind uns
einig dass wir in diese Gespräche gehen
war das war die große Mehrheit wie ich
jetzt gesagt habe im Präsidium ja es gab
auch andere Stimmen die gesagt haben
nein wir finden jetzt sollten die
anderen erstmal miteinander sprechen das
ist so und deswegen sage ich das hier
auch in alle Offenheit aber es gibt eben
diese große Mehrheit im Präsidium und zu
der Frage von und zu der Frage der
sondierungskoalitionsfähigkeit das ist
eindeutig wenn CDU und CSU das Angebot
machen zu Gesprächen dann stehen wir da
zusammen und machen ein gutes Angebot
und dann muss man schauen wie damit
umgegangen wird
ja sie haben also ich kann Ihnen das ich
bin jetzt nicht derjenige der jetzt
berichtet was jeder einzeln gesagt hat
aber ich glaube es ist bekannt dass der
sächsische Ministerpräsident dort eine
etwas andere Sichtweise hat auf die
Dinge die nächste Frage Frau Siewert von
Focus bitte
vielen Dank ich habe auch zwei Fragen
zum einen gibt es einen bestimmten Grund
dafür dass die CDU und die CSU jeweils
erst einmal getrennt vor sondieren um
sich dann am Sonntag noch mal zu treffen
und gemeinsam zu besprechen wie man in
diese Treffen hineingeht und das zweite
woran hat es am Ende bei dem Termin am
Samstag
/ Freitag gelegen also war es dann nur
die basiskonferenz was der Geburtstag
von Edmund Stoiber
zieht man diesen Geburtstag dann
Sondierungsgesprächen möglicherweise vor
ja das war's danke also erstens bereiten
CDU und CSU diese Gespräche gemeinsam
vor wir haben ein gemeinsames
Wahlprogramm wir haben eine starke
gemeinsame Bundestagsfraktion und
deswegen bereiten wir die Gespräche
gemeinsam vor und sowohl die
Parteivorsitzenden als auch im Markus
Blum und ich als genau heilsekretäre
sind in ständigem Austausch auch in den
Blick auf diese Gespräche und deswegen
gibt es dort überhaupt keine Diskussion
das wird gemeinsam vorbereitet das ist
der erste Punkt der zweite Punkt ist zu
der Frage der Terminfindung man schaut
welche Termine passen welche sinnvoll
sind wir wissen das zum Beispiel am
Sonntag der Staatsakt ist zum Tag der
Deutschen Einheit das ist wichtig für
unser Land und deswegen findet auch
nicht parallel beispielsweise eine
entsprechendes Gespräch statt und dann
haben wir uns darauf verständigt dass
wir Sonntagabend zusammenkommen das ist
ein guter Termin und wir alle wollen
miteinander sprechen das kann ich sagen
für CDU und CSU
das Wichtigste ist dass wir jetzt die
Dinge gut vorbereiten auch für die
Besprechung wir treffen uns ja
sicherlich vorher gemeinsam CDU und CSU
und Markus Blume und ich sind da im
ständigen Austausch und bereiten das vor
Herr Rinke von Reuters bitte erzähl mir
eine Frage nach dem Verhandlungsteam
können Sie uns sagen wie viele Vertreter
auf cdu-seite dabei sein sollen und wer
das genau ist und zweite Frage ist es
möglich dass man während der Sondierung
oder zum Abschluss der Sondierungen dann
noch den CDU-Chef als Verhandlungsführer
austauscht
also im Verhandlungsteam sind der
Parteivorsitzende Kanzlerkandidat
arminlaschet ich als Generalsekretär der
Fraktionsvorsitzende Ralf Brinkhaus die
Ministerpräsidenten wo viel und Günther
sowie Haseloff Thomas Strobl Julia
Klöckner Silvia breher und Jens Spahn
es gibt keine Diskussion darüber
das sondierungsteam ist ja jetzt wieder
ziemlich groß ist diese Anzahl der
Personen die Reaktion darauf dass die
CSU 5 Mitglieder möchte und haben sie
keine Sorge dass das sondierungs-team
von Anfang an zu groß ist nein dass das
diese Sorge habe ich nicht es geht darum
dass es was uns wichtig ist und auch den
anderen das Vertraulichkeit gewahrt wird
das zeigen ja die Erfahrung aus der
Vergangenheit dass so etwas eine
Arbeitsatmosphäre sehr belasten kann das
ist uns sehr wichtig und uns geht es um
die inhaltliche Ausrichtung auf
Grundlage eines Angebots das alle
Parteien machen mit ihren jeweiligen
Ergebnissen bei dieser Bundestagswahl
geht es darum zu schauen wo sind
Gemeinsamkeiten und wenn man Brücken
bauen möchte dann muss man sich
anschauen wo sind denn die Ufer wie lang
sind die Wege
hat man eine gemeinsame Idee davon wie
man dieses Land führen möchte und wenn
das der Fall ist dann kann daraus eine
gute Koalition werden aber das muss man
sehen dafür ist es jetzt noch sehr sehr
früh noch mal im Lichte dieser
Ergebnisse der Bundestagswahl die die
uns sehr bewusst sind auch was das für
die Union bedeutet machen wir ein
inhaltliches Angebot
danach zwei Fragen Frau kirschik zuerst
und dann Frau Schweizer
die CSU ist ja vorgeprescht am Dienstag
noch mal und hat gesagt ja sie hatten
jetzt schon so eine Matrix vorbereitet
wie man denn die Verhandlungen führen
würde was denn da zur Sprache käme und
so weiter inwieweit spielt das bei den
Sondierungen eine Rolle
also die CSU ist immer gut vorbereitet
und es spielt was wir gemeinsam
erarbeiten auch in den Häusern so ist es
ja die Parteizentralen schauen natürlich
darauf dass man bestimmte Dinge
vorbereitet das tun Markus Blume und ich
gemeinsam und natürlich spielt das alles
eine Rolle aber in den ersten Gesprächen
geht es glaube ich noch einmal mehr um
den Überbau in dieser Konstellation man
muss ja eine Vorstellung davon haben wie
was die Zielsetzung einer solchen
Koalition sein könnte und dann geht es
weiter mit eben immer weiter in die
Tiefe der Gespräche zu einzelnen Punkten
und danach war Schweiz auf einer ARD
bitte letzte Frage sie haben sicherlich
auch einen Fahrplan dafür wenn diese
Dinge scheitern sollten diese
Verhandlungen wie wird sich dann die
Partei neu aufstellen das heißt es auch
für den Parteivorsitzende
also wir sind uns einig und das haben
wir gesehen bei dieser Wahl dass uns
dieses Ergebnis dass wir eingefahren
haben so muss man es sagen nicht kalt
lässt und das heißt unabhängig von der
Frage ob wir regieren oder nicht
regieren es ja kein selbstweg sondern es
geht um die Gestaltung des Landes kriegt
man etwas Gutes hin mit einem
gemeinsamen Geist und narrativ muss ich
natürlich die Partei erneuern und
modernisieren und das ist wie gesagt
unabhängig von der Frage regieren oder
nicht und daran werden wir und arbeiten
wir auch schon parallel ich war auch in
verschiedenen schalten bin es jetzt
heute mit den jüngeren bei uns in der
Partei und morgen mit unseren
Kommunalpolitikerinnen und
Kommunalpolitikern wo es um diese Frage
geht das Wahlergebnis muss ja nicht nur
analysiert werden sondern daraus müssen
ja Schlussfolgerungen gezogen werden
aber das tun wir jetzt gleichzeitig und
zu Ihrer Frage alles weitere zeigt sich
in der Frage wie diese Gespräche weiter
dann vielen Dank fürs Kommen vielen Dank
Herr ziemiak alles Gute schönen Tag noch
danke Ihnen